yeah I want to welcome you to this video
my way I don't know what what does he do
that we should be fired I don't quite
think he plays the open okay early c3 I
had some tricky business him I think
there's some tricky business there yeah
he plays any address an official game he
595 and Quincy form there are some stuff
like that but i think that black has
good compensation there fischeri to the
rich or something something like that
the very weak memory but I think there
is something like that
the strange-looking more if I kobe 6 he
has to go 24
now in the day that is a good move I
generally fine i just wonder wonder if
this is the best i can take and play
something like 85 appreciably six I
wonder I am nitey 5c will go back that
it doesn't do much I can also just take
you five I think I want to speed up this
a little bit I wonder if d3 is actually
a movie for Bishop a6 queen for just
trying to cover everything a d3 is may
be necessary I don't see how it is ever
going to Castle if it doesn't do that
yeah this intent is really okay
now I need to play temple moves here
flavored temple takes Queen takes than
this is a temple on the pond and ok you
can go we fix that this is not not a
good solution is sick so probably just
take
i 95 it looks I mean he doesn't have any
development mighty to work i'm in my
life my light and squares are weakest
and I should find more or less mandatory
otherwise the sisters make any sense
maybe I can play well not for me not
fitting that you 595 is probably too
much you can take only six and if that
doesn't look good
alrighty hi I mean I don't see them I
don't see anything great after 95 maybe
is concerned about 95 and 96 p.m. i will
get this back I mean still 195 neither
just take their I mean yeah I think it
works actually so we go see fall which
gives me time for Queen to dissemble
okay he can go at four but that also
weakens quite a bit might still be the
best book I mean knight c6 986 okay what
now what now yeah my bishop is hanging
king at seven takes it's no good please
calm down I have the clearly better
development pins but i'm not sure how
much that counts
even though they have some compensation
but enough I don't know I don't know if
it's enough not so easy to to play for
white yeah I cannot take quite clearly
I'm not sure what to do here Quincy form
a becomes tough position now you might
take it home time morning okay let's put
this on the non-diagonal for some
potential counterplay yeah this is a
cool my night my queen s square oh my
god now he has tricked me again is such
a tricky player I mean that position was
was clearly blank sign clearly good
compensation but i didn't i didn't play
it right left at home opening with Queen
84 come on yeah so let's there's no
check how how I could have punished this
letter yeah I mean maybe I should just
start to play simple move that this is
clearly okay for blankets is very very
obvious but it didn't didn't seem enough
for me to punish this Queen 84 Quincy
for Queens if I Quincy for this is like
something that should be punished but
yeah maybe this isn't this isn't it's
difficult to place a thing I mean even
though it must be okay for black still
have to play it and now aged 6 yeah yeah
maybe this is right I mean now my
position is becomes very very very murky
and it's all good iam so defy this is
the one to play pawn takes us back home
before I mean assault at d5 ism I
completely forgot that he cannot go to
III has to cover this bloody thing so we
have to go somewhere else
ya got queener is 7i short but there
should be three okay but 94 is good here
whoa there i also saw that that cover
that and now so it's not good yet yeah
this is the big blunder of course hmm
mayorships just a simple chest and not
try to punish people for their bad play
too hot now just taking five is of
course good for like I mean quite clear
you get to pawn back and then you'll
find I mean what kind of stuff is that
but I felt this is the kind of game that
should be one in 20 moves with mate but
ok just it is it is looking somehow it's
looking somehow and here you need to
play extremely precisely which I didn't
h6 is interesting that this is a good
move it makes perfect sense i mean you
have to take now when we find otherwise
I'm just yeah yeah I mean something like
that is clearly gleeful like him some
kind of thing like that it's equal
material I've got the bishop pair and so
on so we have to take here and this is
very messy nah mean ok this looks fine
yeah I should just kick in fact I mean
it's what it is just get the phone back
and out wide what all this nonsense like
a queen knows did this is what i should
do here now ok thanks for watching